[Música]
hola bienvenidos a áfrica 7 días está en
su magazine 100 dedicado al continente
africano mi nombre es andrés meza muñoz
y estos son nuestros titulares la crisis
diplomática y militar entre malí y
francia está sellada el presidente
francés emmanuel macrón anunció el fin
de la operación barkan y la retirada de
las tropas francesas del país africano
pero sin abandonar el sahel
la unión europea y la unión africana
celebraron en bruselas un acuerdo de
colaboración económica que incluye una
ayuda para la producción de vacunas
contra el cobre 19 en áfrica la
especialista en salud de france 24 nos
ofrecerá un análisis
iremos a cotonou la capital de benin
tres meses después de su restitución por
parte de francia 26 obras saqueadas a
finales del siglo 19 por tropas
coloniales fueron eximidas por primera
vez en el palacio presidencial
llegó al final de la operación marcan
tras casi una década de presencia
militar en el norte de mali el
presidente francés emmanuel macrón
anunció la retirada de las tropas
francesas de este país junto con sus
socios africanos y europeos -francia
justificó su decisión argumentando que
ya no se dan las condiciones para la
lucha contra el terrorismo en mali el
país galo citó como ejemplo la
colaboración de la junta maliense en el
poder con mercenarios de la empresa rusa
wagner escuchemos al presidente francés
sobre las razones y condiciones de la
retirada con jus definan ita cuando
tenemos un estado que decide aliarse con
mercenarios privados que deja de ser
claro en su lucha contra el terrorismo y
que decide dejar de colaborar con
nosotros en este caso ya no depende de
nosotros seguir avanzando para mí esto
está completamente claro tick completo
hemos empezado a cerrar las bases en el
norte cerraremos de manera gradual en un
ejercicio que durará de cuatro a seis
meses todas las bases en mali durante
este tiempo desplegaremos importantes
fuerzas tanto de seguridad como
logística para asegurar nuestra retirada
pero aunque la operación barkan ha
llegado a su fin en mali a manuel macro
na que la acción militar de su país se
mantendrá en la región para según dijo
frenar el peligro yihadista que sigue
extendiéndose hacia los países costeros
de áfrica occidental veamos el siguiente
mapa las tropas francesas se concentran
en el norte de mali la zona más afectada
por la violencia yihadista en rojo
podemos ver en goce ko y mena acá las
bases militares que cerrarán y aquí en
color naranja de shalit kidal y tombuctú
las que ya han cerrado en junio de 2021
mientras que en senegal níger y chad
están las bases francesas que seguirán
activas y hacia las que seguramente se
desplazarán los soldados franceses que
se encuentran actualmente en mal
ahora que francia prepara su salida de
malí echemos una mirada retrospectiva a
la que fue la operación barca
la operación marcan empieza en 2014
después de que un violento movimiento
yihadista infiltrado en la rebelión de
las poblaciones tuareg del norte de mali
comenzará a cobrar fuerza francia decide
entonces intervenir
y
quiero decirles que el gobierno francés
tiene una determinación total en la
implementación de la operación marcada y
en la lucha contra el terrorismo
pero la estrategia francesa se encuentra
dificultada por la guerra civil en libia
desatada tras la intervención de la otan
en el país norteafricano en 2011 para
derrocar al coronel moamar gadafi en
2015 francia esperaba celebrar un
acuerdo de paz entre el estado central
de malí y algunos de los grupos touareg
del norte se suponía que este acuerdo
negociado bajo el patrocinado de argelia
sería una de las herramientas para
apartar a los yihadistas pero se
convirtió en una de las fuentes de
distensión entre parís y bamako y las
autoridades malienses culparon a francia
de querer dividir al país
recordamos que esta intervención después
de haber ayudado inicialmente a repelar
a los grupos terroristas se convirtió en
una partición de facto de malí en 2016
la situación se deteriora aún más por
limitaciones de capacidad francia nunca
desplegó sus tropas en el centro de
miami la sola también abandonada por las
autoridades malienses dio gradualmente a
los chavistas ganar terreno en 2020 un
golpe de estado derrocó al presidente
maliense ibrahim abu bakr keita hasta
entonces el principal vigilante de la
operación marcando luego los desacuerdos
aumentan dentro del gobierno de
transición maliense lo que lleva a un
nuevo golpe de estado en mayo de 2021 y
ha relaciones cada vez más tensas con
parís
en diciembre de 2021 la supuesta llegada
de centenares de paramilitares de la
cuestionada empresa privada wagner pone
un punto final al ciclo de desconfianza
cambiamos de tema unas horas después de
que francia formalizará su retirada
militar de malí el jueves 17 de febrero
comenzó en bruselas la sexta cumbre
unión europea- áfrica la reunión fue una
oportunidad para que europa anunciara
una estrategia de inversión global con
al menos 150 mil millones de euros para
financiar proyectos en áfrica dando
prioridad a las infraestructuras de
transporte las redes digitales y la
energía pero los europeos se
comprometieron sobre todo a ayudar a los
países africanos a producir vacunas de
aire n mensajero un programa anunciado
por la organización mundial de la salud
es tal vez un paso hacia una menor
desigualdad en las vacunas sudáfrica
egipto nigeria kenia senegal y túnez
pronto albergarán su propia producción
de vacunas de aire mensajero
[Aplausos]
se trata de crear tecnología de aire en
mensajeros en áfrica liderada por áfrica
y propiedad de áfrica con el apoyo de
europa se soporta opción mayor el
presidente decidí ramaphosa ha exigido
una vez más que se levanten las patentes
de las empresas farmacéuticas
occidentales con el fin de consolidar de
forma sostenible las industrias del
continente y es nora séptimo no es
aceptable que áfrica esté constantemente
al final de la fila en relación con el
acceso a los medicamentos
si bien apreciamos las donaciones nunca
son una forma sostenible o un mecanismo
para desarrollar la resiliencia imágenes
de capel resiliente opuestos al
levantamiento de patentes curso y la
fundar legend y enmanuel macrón
defendieron la elección de una
transparencia de tecnología incluida la
más confidencial una solución que según
ellos protege la propiedad intelectual
proteger la propiedad intelectual porque
es muy importante para nosotros seguir
creando innovando e inventando tenemos
que respetar eso
actualmente el 1 por ciento de las
vacunas utilizadas en áfrica se producen
en el continente el objetivo es aumentar
esta cifra al 60 por ciento para 2040
estas nuevas unidades destinadas primero
a luchar contra el coi 19 podrán
eventualmente producir tratamientos como
insulina y medicamentos contra el cáncer
así como otras vacunas en particular
contra la malaria y el vih
y para analizar este tema de la
producción de vacunas en áfrica
recibimos a mar romero periodista en
france24 especializada en salud mar en
qué consiste exactamente el anuncio de
lado de mesa y cuál es la diferencia con
la liberación de las patentes
lo que ha anunciado la organización
mundial de la salud desde esto como
decía es una transferencia de tecnología
cabe recordar que esta tecnología de a
rené mensajero no es exclusiva de facer
o de moderna lo que es exclusivo de
estas farmacéuticas es como la han usado
para desarrollar una vacuna contra el
kobe 19 entonces la organización mundial
de la salud con otras organizaciones y
otras entidades que también lo están
apoyando van a crear una especie de
centros tecnológicos van a formar a
profesionales de la salud en estos
países africanos van a dar los equipos
necesarios para que estas personas
puedan desarrollar sus propias vacunas
contra el cob en 19 usando este tipo de
tecnología la diferencia con la
liberación de las patentes es que al
final si se liberarán las patentes se
daría una especie de receta paso a paso
con exactamente todos los ingredientes
que se tiene que hacer para crear estas
vacunas de kobe 19 contra el comic 19
con la tecnología de reno mensajero
mientras que esta transferencia de
tecnología al final supone cómo dar los
ingredientes dar un cierto conocimiento
alrededor de este tema para que luego
estas personas puedan desarrollar sus
propios productos por supuesto sería
mucho más para todo el continente
africano y para estos centros
tecnológicos si se liberarán las
patentes si tuvieran acceso a esta
receta en vez de tener que hacer todos
los ensayos clínicos desarrollar nuevas
vacunas pero sin duda es un paso hacia
adelante
y ahora que cambiará para áfrica tras
este anuncio de la un
la verdad es que sería optimista pensar
que con esta solución se va a solucionar
ya la desigualdad en términos de la
vacunación contra el comicio 9 del
continente africano respecto al resto
del mundo pero es un paso hacia adelante
porque podemos puede ser que a medio a
largo plazo quizás en unos 23 años
empecemos a ver resultados es decir que
se solucione algo de esta dependencia
que tiene el continente africano
respecto a los países del norte global
para obtener vacunas hay un dato que es
especialmente alarmante y es que sólo un
1% de todas las vacunas que se inoculan
en áfrica no sólo del cobi 19 sino
también de otras enfermedades están
producidas en el mismo continente
entonces estos centros tecnológicos
pueden empezar a ser una solución para
que el continente africano y estos
países tengan algo más de autonomía a la
hora de desarrollar sus propios fármacos
y también pues de implementar sus
campañas de vacunación sobre todo
también porque esta tecnología de arene
mensajero no solo puede servir en
vacunas contra el comil 19 sino que se
cree que puede ser la clave para luchar
contra enfermedades como el vih la
malaria la tuberculosis enfermedades que
de hecho en el continente africano
tienen una alta incidencia entonces por
eso así no sea una liberación de las
patentes sigue siendo un motivo del cual
nos podemos alegrar pues bien era más
romeros periodista en france24
especializada en salud muchas gracias
por esta explicación y terminamos en con
tono la capital de benin donde se
exhibieron las 26 obras del reino de
abomey que fueron restituidas por
francia el año pasado a pesar de que los
bronces de benin son una colección
constituida por más de 1000 piezas
conmemorativas el presidente de esta
nación asegura que no pretende recuperar
todas pues desea que sean expuestas en
todo el mundo
más de un siglo de exilio dos años de
negociaciones con parís y tres meses
después de su regreso a venir las 26
horas del reino de a gómez finalmente se
exhiben en el palacio presidencial en
cotonou el jefe de estado- beninés quien
negoció la restitución como una
prioridad desde su elección en 2016
entregó las obras a los descendientes de
dignatarios de los antiguos reinos de
benin
causalidad
pedimos más obras pero fue parís quien
eligió no vamos a pedir que se devuelva
todo las obras beninesas deben
permanecer en los museos de todo el
mundo para que el planeta pueda ver la
grandeza de venían
como las tres horas saqueados en 1892
por las tropas coloniales francesas del
palacio de a gómez en el centro de benin
pero el país quiere seguir recuperando
otras obras un mensaje recibido por la
ministra de cultura francesa presente en
la inauguración para roselyne bachelot
francia debe como desea de manuel macrón
desempeñar su papel en la reapropiación
de los africanos de su patrimonio se la
voluntad
es la voluntad de escribir otra historia
de recrear a partir de este patrimonio
memorial histórico y estético y vemos
artistas benineses absolutamente
notables y estoy bien y no sólo con las
que hable
de hecho 34 artistas contemporáneos se
exponen junto a las obras restauradas
para ilustrar la continuidad de la
riqueza cultural de benin
de esta manera despedimos esta emisión
de áfrica siete días gracias por
acompañarnos recuerda que si quieres
repetir esta u otra edición de nuestro
programa lo puede hacer a través de
nuestra página web www punto frente a 24
punto com
[Música]